A splash of fresh water will reach the depths of your heart. Those mighty blue waves can propel you forward or they can calm and soothe. Coast to Michigan coast. Simply feel the flow in the moment. And let those vast lakes, rivers and streams create everlasting memories. Jump right in and let fresh wash over you in Pure Michigan. Keep it fresh at Michigan.org. Or on our website.
清凉的泉水将触及你心灵深处。那汹涌的蓝色波浪可以推动你前行，也可以让你平静舒缓。从密歇根海岸到海岸。只需感受当下的流动。让那些广阔的湖泊、河流和溪流创造永恒的记忆。纵身跃入，让纯净的密歇根洗涤你的身心。在 Michigan.org 保持清爽。或访问我们的网站。
It was cold and rainy in Los Angeles County on the morning of Wednesday, January 26, 2005. Shortly before 6am, Jenny Dole pulled into the deserted car park of the Costco retail warehouse in Glendale, a suburb 10 miles north of downtown LA. While dark, quiet and dreary outside, the interior of the Costco was bright and bustling with employees preparing for the day ahead. Jenny began work at the loading dock. A few minutes into her shift, a thunderous roar blasted through the building causing the entire warehouse to shake. Within moments, the area fell eerily silent. Jenny stopped what she was doing and looked anxiously at those around her.
2005年1月26日星期三清晨，洛杉矶县阴雨绵绵，天气寒冷。清晨6点前不久，珍妮·多尔（Jenny Dole）将车开进了位于格伦代尔（Glendale）的好市多（Costco）零售仓库的空旷停车场，格伦代尔是洛杉矶市中心以北10英里处的一个郊区。虽然外面天色昏暗、安静而阴沉，但好市多内部却灯火通明，员工们正忙碌地为新的一天做准备。珍妮在装卸码头开始工作。轮班开始几分钟后，一声震耳欲聋的巨响在建筑物内炸开，导致整个仓库剧烈摇晃。片刻之内，该区域陷入了诡异的寂静。珍妮停下手中的工作，焦虑地看着周围的人。
Once their shock had worn off, the workers rushed out to investigate the source of the frightening noise. Early that morning, engineer Bruce Gray boarded a Metro Link 100, a blue and white double-decker train headed for downtown LA. Over 100 commuters were spread out behind him on the train's upper and lower compartments. Bruce entered the front carriage and took his position behind the controls. Metro Link 100 reached the speed of around 80mph as it hurdled from station to station. Soon, the train was on the outskirts of the city, heading south towards Glendale. As its headlights pierced the pre-dawn darkness, Bruce Gray noticed something glint up ahead. Parked on the rails was a green Jeep Cherokee SUV.
震惊过后，工人们冲出去调查这可怕噪音的来源。那天清晨，工程师布鲁斯·格雷（Bruce Gray）登上了一列开往洛杉矶市中心的蓝白双层列车——Metrolink 100次列车。在他身后的列车上下车厢里，坐着100多名通勤者。布鲁斯进入前车厢，在操纵台后就位。Metrolink 100次列车以每小时约80英里的速度在车站之间飞驰。很快，列车到达城市郊区，向南驶向格伦代尔。当车头灯刺破黎明前的黑暗时，布鲁斯·格雷注意到前方有东西在闪光。一辆绿色的吉普切诺基（Jeep Cherokee）SUV停在铁轨上。
It was sitting a little further up from the Chevy Chase Drive crossing. Its headlights were off. Bruce couldn't see anyone near it. He slammed on the emergency brakes and shut off the throttle, but it was too late. Knowing the train had no chance of stopping in time, Bruce ran through the carriage behind him, yelling at passengers to hold on. Seconds later, the train collided with the Jeep at approximately 63mph. The Jeep overturned and embedded under the front of the first carriage. The grinding metal on metal produced hot sparks that triggered a blaze at the collision point. It spread quickly through the first undercarriage.
它停在离雪佛兰大通大道（Chevy Chase Drive）交叉口稍远一点的地方。车灯是关着的。布鲁斯看不到附近有人。他猛踩紧急制动器并关闭油门，但为时已晚。布鲁斯知道列车不可能及时停下，于是跑过身后的车厢，大声叫喊让乘客抓稳。几秒钟后，列车以大约每小时63英里的速度撞上了吉普车。吉普车翻倒并嵌入第一节车厢的前部。金属摩擦产生的热火花在碰撞点引发了大火。火势迅速蔓延到第一节底盘。
The screams of commuters echoed down the remaining carriages, accompanied by the loud crashing noises caused by the fiery impact. Because of the Jeep's comparative size, the collision did little to slow the train. It continued along for 250 yards to where the track split in two. The front part of the first passenger carriage exited and travelled along the sidetrack, while its rear and the remaining carriages continued along the main line. The lights inside the train flickered out. Commuters felt silent. All they could hear was the screeching of the undercarriage as it dragged across gravel. They braced themselves in nervous anticipation. It was common for trains to be parked on the sidetrack when not in use.
通勤者的尖叫声在其余车厢中回荡，伴随着火热撞击产生的巨大破碎声。由于吉普车的体积相对较小，这次碰撞几乎没有减缓列车的速度。列车继续前行了250码，到达了轨道分叉处。第一节客车车厢的前部脱轨并沿着侧线行驶，而其后部和其余车厢则继续沿主线行驶。列车内的灯光闪烁熄灭。通勤者们沉默了。他们只能听到车底盘在碎石上拖行的刺耳声。他们紧张地屏住呼吸，严阵以待。火车不使用时停在侧线上是很常见的。
On this occasion, a freight train was dormant on the sidetrack and had been for several days. It contained construction materials used to repair a portion of the track further north that had been damaged from a recent mudslide. Now split between both the main line and sidetrack, the front passenger carriage of Metrolink 100 collided with the stationery freight train at about 47 miles per hour. Half the carriage was crushed on impact. Passengers inside were violently thrown from their seats, with some landing on the tracks outside. Smoke filled the air as the train jackknifed across the tracks and derailed, spilling debris everywhere. Travelling in the opposite direction was another double-decker passenger train. Engineer Thomas Ormiston was operating Metrolink 901 heading north from downtown LA.
这一次，一列货运列车已经在侧线上停放了几天。它装载着用于修复北部因近期泥石流而受损的轨道部分的建筑材料。现在，Metrolink 100次列车的第一节客车车厢横跨主线和侧线，以每小时约47英里的速度撞上了静止的货运列车。半节车厢在撞击中被压碎。车内乘客被猛烈地甩出座位，一些人落在了外面的轨道上。随着列车在轨道上折叠并脱轨，碎片四处飞溅，空气中弥漫着烟雾。另一列双层客运列车正朝相反方向行驶。工程师托马斯·奥米斯顿（Thomas Ormiston）正在驾驶从洛杉矶市中心向北行驶的Metrolink 901次列车。
Thomas was on schedule, having just departed Glendale Station. Within moments, his train sped into the crash site ahead. The first two passenger carriages of the 901 narrowly cleared the accident between Metrolink 100 and the freight train. Had it not been for the jackknife effect caused by the collision, Metrolink 901 would have passed through the area unscathed. However, Metrolink 100 raked down the entire side of the final passenger carriage of the 901, completely caving it in on one side. As the 901 was travelling at approximately 50 miles per hour, the impact caused all three of its passenger carriages to derail and topple over. An overhead signal tower also sustained damage, falling and crashing onto one of the carriages. Debris from the three train wrecks spilled over into the parking lot of the nearby Costco.
托马斯按计划行驶，刚刚离开格伦代尔站。片刻之内，他的列车加速驶入前方的事故现场。901次列车的前两节客车车厢险之又险地避开了Metrolink 100次列车与货运列车之间的事故。如果不是因为碰撞产生的折叠效应，Metrolink 901次列车本可以安然无恙地通过该区域。然而，Metrolink 100次列车刮擦了901次列车最后一节客车车厢的整个侧面，使其一侧完全塌陷。由于901次列车当时以每小时约50英里的速度行驶，撞击导致其所有三节客车车厢脱轨并翻倒。一座高架信号塔也受到损坏，倒塌并砸在其中一节车厢上。三列火车的残骸碎片散落到附近好市多的停车场。
Employees emerged from the building and rushed to the scene armed with fire extinguishers. They desperately battled the flames engulfing the front carriage of Metrolink 100, which were reaching 20 feet high. A Costco employee retrieved a forklift from the warehouse to try to dislodge some of the wreckage to reach those trapped inside. Others risked their own lives by directly pulling people from the wreck, which was so damaged it hardly resembled a carriage. When leaking diesel fuel soaked their clothes, they were forced to ease back or risk catching fire. Yet, they managed to pull out one final victim before retreating, a man covered in blood and soot. All of his limbs appeared to be broken and his face was charred black. As he was lifted out, the injured man profusely thanked his rescuers.
员工们从大楼里冲出来，拿着灭火器赶到现场。他们拼命扑灭Metrolink 100次列车前车厢的大火，火势高达20英尺。一名好市多员工从仓库取来叉车，试图移开一些残骸，以营救被困在里面的人。其他人冒着生命危险直接将人从残骸中拉出来，残骸损坏严重，几乎看不出是车厢。当泄漏的柴油浸透他们的衣服时，他们被迫后退，否则就有起火的危险。然而，在撤退前，他们还是成功拉出了最后一名受害者，一个浑身是血和煤烟的男人。他的四肢似乎都断了，脸也被烧成了黑色。当他被抬出来时，受伤的男子不停地感谢他的救命恩人。
He asked them to pray for him before closing his eyes. Minutes later, he passed away. He was one of 11 fatalities. Eight people had died on Metrolink 100. The remainder were on board Metrolink 901. At 6.03 am, three short beeps came over the radio of the LAPD's northeast division. An announcement followed, explaining that there had been a train derailment at Glendale. Officers raced to the location. They were confronted by a thick cloud of smoke that reaped of diesel fuel.
他请求他们为他祈祷，然后闭上了眼睛。几分钟后，他去世了。他是11名遇难者之一。8人死于Metrolink 100次列车。其余人在Metrolink 901次列车上。凌晨6点03分，洛杉矶警察局东北分局的无线电中传出三声短促的蜂鸣声。随后发布了一则公告，解释说格伦代尔发生了一起火车脱轨事故。警察赶往现场。他们面对的是一团散发着柴油味的浓烟。
It shadowed a chaotic scene. A dazed and frantic crowd had gathered in the parking light of the nearby Costco. Almost 200 people bore injuries. Those in the worst condition were being wheeled around in store carts. Others were shaken, but able to walk. The adjacent train tracks were a mess of twisted and burning metal. Firefighters extinguished the accompanying blaze, allowing responders to retrieve the remaining passengers scattered throughout the crash site. They had sustained fractured bones, head injuries, lacerations, and in some cases, impalement from train debris.
烟雾笼罩着混乱的现场。一群惊魂未定、陷入疯狂的人群聚集在附近好市多的停车场。近200人受伤。伤势最重的人被放在商店的手推车里推着走。其他人虽然受到惊吓，但还能行走。相邻的铁轨上是一片扭曲和燃烧的金属残骸。消防员扑灭了随之而来的大火，救援人员得以搜救散落在事故现场各处的其余乘客。他们遭受了骨折、头部受伤、撕裂伤，在某些情况下，还被火车碎片刺穿身体。
The cause of the crash, the Jeep Cherokee SUV, was near obliterated. Pieces of the vehicle were scattered over 300 yards. What was left of the Jeep's chassis was still lodged upside down under the burnt remains of Metrolink 100's front passenger carriage. Even though the vehicle's fuel tank was warped by heat, it remained intact. It contained almost 12 gallons of gasoline, meaning it was almost full. Investigators walked along the track examining the remains of the Jeep. They located two plastic one-gallon water bottles that had been in the vehicle, along with a headrest, a poultry from the passenger side door and back seat, weather stripping from around the rear window, and two pieces of moulding from the roof.
事故的起因——那辆吉普切诺基SUV几乎被彻底摧毁。车辆碎片散落在300码的范围内。吉普车底盘的残骸仍然倒扣在Metrolink 100次列车烧毁的前客车车厢下。尽管车辆的油箱因受热而变形，但它仍然完好无损。里面装有近12加仑汽油，这意味着它几乎是满的。调查人员沿着轨道走着，检查吉普车的残骸。他们发现了车内留下的两个塑料一加仑水瓶，以及一个头枕、乘客侧车门和后座的装饰条、后窗周围的密封条，还有两块车顶模具。
Even though the Jeep's fuel tank was intact, all of these items tested positive for gasoline. They also located the tailgate with the license plate attached. A witness emerged who had seen the Jeep moments prior to the crash. It was driving along Chevy Chase Drive before pulling off to continue along the side road parallel to the railway lines. It was put in park and a male driver got out. He then poured liquid from a large jug all over the exterior of the vehicle, starting on the roof and then moving to the hood and rear. Once the bottle was empty, the man got back into the Jeep and continued driving down the side road until he found an entry point onto the train line. He then parked the vehicle on the tracks and waited.
尽管吉普车的油箱完好无损，但所有这些物品的汽油检测均呈阳性。他们还找到了带有车牌的后挡板。一名目击者出现了，他在事故发生前几分钟看到了这辆吉普车。它沿着雪佛兰大通大道行驶，然后转弯继续沿着铁路线平行的侧路行驶。车停了下来，一名男性司机走了出来。然后，他将一个大壶里的液体倒在车身外部，从车顶开始，然后移动到引擎盖和后部。瓶子空了之后，那人回到吉普车里，继续沿着侧路行驶，直到找到一个进入铁路线的入口。然后他把车停在铁轨上，等待着。
The 35-year-old Juan Manuel Alvarez had a rough start in life. Born in 1979, Juan grew up in Mexicali, a city along the US-Mexico border. He was beaten and abused by his alcoholic and drug-dealing father, who had been a professional boxer. After one particularly brutal attack, Juan's father tied him to a table overnight. On another occasion, eight-year-old Juan was pulled from his home by his older sister, Cynthia. Once outside, Cynthia watched through a window as her father beat their mother so severely that blood soaked her face. They were both mouthing words at Cynthia, but she couldn't make out what they were saying. Turning around, Cynthia saw Juan trying to hang himself.
35岁的胡安·曼努埃尔·阿尔瓦雷斯（Juan Manuel Alvarez）的人生开局很艰难。胡安出生于1979年，在美墨边境城市墨西加利（Mexicali）长大。他经常被酗酒和贩毒的父亲殴打和虐待，他的父亲曾是一名职业拳击手。在一次特别残酷的袭击后，胡安的父亲把他绑在桌子上过了一夜。另一次，8岁的胡安被姐姐辛西娅（Cynthia）从家里拉了出来。到了外面，辛西娅透过窗户看到父亲殴打他们的母亲，母亲的脸被血浸透。他们都在对辛西娅嘟囔着什么，但她听不清他们在说什么。转过身，辛西娅看到胡安试图上吊自杀。
Their father came outside and rescued him. A short while after, Juan tried to take his own life again, this time by jumping in front of a moving bus. His grandmother pulled him to safety just in time. As a child, Juan claimed he was molested by an uncle. Around this time, he started having delusions. Juan featured an evil spirit that entered Juan's room at night, crawled into his bed, and slept next to him. When Juan spoke of this nightmare, he would zone out and stare into nothingness. At age 12, Juan moved to LA.
他们的父亲出来救了他。不久之后，胡安再次试图结束自己的生命，这次是跳到一辆行驶的公共汽车前。他的祖母及时把他拉到了安全地带。小时候，胡安声称自己被叔叔猥亵过。大约在这个时候，他开始产生幻觉。胡安说有一个恶灵，晚上会进入胡安的房间，爬上他的床，睡在他旁边。当胡安谈到这个噩梦时，他会走神，盯着虚空。12岁时，胡安搬到了洛杉矶。
While cannabis helped him cope with his troubled past, it took harder drugs to keep the delusions at bay. Juan developed a cocaine and methamphetamine addiction, but they only fueled his disassociation from reality. He spoke of hearing voices and seeing people who weren't there. In 1999, Juan Alvarez married a woman named Carmelita. He raised Carmelita's daughter, and the couple had a son of their own. Juan enjoyed fatherhood and worked construction jobs to support his family, but was never able to shake his methamphetamine habit, even getting higher when looking after his children. In 2004, Juan badly injured his arm at a work site.
虽然大麻帮助他应对困扰的过去，但需要更强烈的毒品才能抑制幻觉。胡安对可卡因和甲基苯丙胺产生了依赖，但这只会加剧他与现实的脱节。他谈到听到声音和看到不存在的人。1999年，胡安·阿尔瓦雷斯与一名叫卡梅利塔（Carmelita）的女子结婚。他抚养了卡梅利塔的女儿，这对夫妇也有了自己的儿子。胡安享受为人父的乐趣，做建筑工作来养家糊口，但始终无法摆脱甲基苯丙胺的习惯，甚至在照顾孩子时也会吸食。2004年，胡安在工地上严重伤了手臂。
As it never completely healed, he was unable to return to the laborious work he relied on. He fell into a deep depression as his financial concerns mounted. Family members sent Juan money to pay off the bills, but his ongoing unemployment and drug addiction ensured that he was never financially sound. After two failed attempts at rehabilitation, Juan was kicked out of home by Carmelita, who also filed a restraining order against him to prevent him from seeing his children. Juan resettled in Glendale. On Saturday, January 22, 2005, Juan phoned Carmelita, begging to see his children.
由于伤口从未完全愈合，他无法回到他所依赖的繁重工作中。随着经济问题的增加，他陷入了深深的抑郁。家庭成员寄钱给胡安支付账单，但他持续的失业和毒瘾确保了他的经济状况从未好转。在两次康复尝试失败后，胡安被卡梅利塔赶出了家门，卡梅利塔还对他申请了限制令，以防止他见到孩子。胡安搬到了格伦代尔。2005年1月22日星期六，胡安打电话给卡梅利塔，恳求见他的孩子。
Carmelita refused, wanting Juan to deal with his demons first. She did allow him to speak to them over the phone. Before ending the call, Juan said to Carmelita, Thank you for letting me talk to the kids. Help prevent shingles in patients over 50 with shingricks. Shingricks is indicated for the prevention of herpes zoster, HZ, or shingles in adults 50 years of age or older. Consult the product monograph at gsk.ca. To request a product monograph or to report an adverse event, please call 1-800-377-374.
卡梅利塔拒绝了，希望胡安先处理好自己的心魔。她确实允许他通过电话与他们交谈。在结束通话前，胡安对卡梅利塔说：“谢谢你让我和孩子们说话。”使用 Shingrix 帮助 50 岁以上患者预防带状疱疹。Shingrix 适用于预防 50 岁或以上成人的带状疱疹（HZ）。请查阅 gsk.ca 上的产品专论。如需索取产品专论或报告不良事件，请致电 1-800-377-374。
Learn more at thinkshinricks.ca. Four days later, on Wednesday, January 26, Juan Alvarez woke early. Despite his weak hand, he'd secured some work on a construction site. He was due at the work site at 7am in Pasadena, eight miles from his home. Juan showered and tied his long black hair into a ponytail to keep it off his face. Before leaving, he warded the roses that bloomed outside his house. He was happy. Life was looking up, and Juan was optimistically waiting on the results of a drug test. The negative result that he expected meant he could see his kids again soon.
在 thinkshinricks.ca 了解更多信息。四天后，1月26日星期三，胡安·阿尔瓦雷斯早早醒来。尽管手部无力，但他还是在建筑工地上找到了一些工作。他原定于上午7点到达帕萨迪纳（Pasadena）的工地，距离他家8英里。胡安洗了个澡，把长长的黑发扎成马尾辫，以免遮住脸。离开前，他浇了浇屋子外面盛开的玫瑰花。他很高兴。生活正在好转，胡安乐观地等待着药检结果。他预期的阴性结果意味着他很快就能再次见到他的孩子们。
By 5.30am, Juan was on the road in his jeep with plenty of time to spare. He headed towards a gas station to fill up his car. On the way, he heard Carmelita in the back seat telling him over and over how stupid he was. She was unrelenting in her taunts. Juan snapped. He filled his tank with gasoline as well as two one-gallon plastic jugs. He had made his decision. Juan was going to set his car on fire with himself inside.
凌晨5点30分，胡安开着他的吉普车上路了，时间绰绰有余。他前往加油站给车加油。路上，他听到后座的卡梅利塔一遍又一遍地告诉他他有多蠢。她的嘲讽毫不留情。胡安崩溃了。他给油箱加满了汽油，还装了两个一加仑的塑料壶。他做出了决定。胡安要连人带车一起点火自焚。
Juan drove around looking for a dark and deserted place. Carmelita continued to berate him from the back seat, now joined by a man whom Juan presumed to be her lover. He stopped briefly at Chevy Chase Park. The park fit his specifications. It was quiet and unlit, with the sun not due to rise for another 90 minutes. Yet Juan was not satisfied and continued along Chevy Chase Drive, then turned into a side street where he parked directly under a streetlight. He emptied one gallon of gasoline over his head and body. He poured the rest all over the exterior and interior of his car. With all the windows and doors closed, Juan sat back into the driver's seat.
胡安开车四处寻找一个黑暗荒凉的地方。卡梅利塔继续在后座责骂他，现在还加入了一个胡安认为是她情人的男人。他在雪佛兰大通公园（Chevy Chase Park）短暂停留。公园符合他的要求。这里安静且没有灯光，距离日出还有90分钟。然而胡安并不满意，继续沿着雪佛兰大通大道行驶，然后转入一条侧街，直接停在路灯下。他把一加仑汽油倒在自己的头上和身上。他把剩下的汽油全部倒在车的外侧和内侧。在所有窗户和车门关闭的情况下，胡安坐回驾驶座。
He felt dizzy and nauseous from the fumes. Hands shaking, he held up a lighter. Again, Juan changed his mind. Burning alive would be a terrible way to die. He drove back up to Chevy Chase Drive and then at the railway crossing entered the restricted area of the tracks and drove parallel to the railroad line for about 50 yards. Juan then parked his car over the tracks. Over the next 15 minutes, he looked at photographs of his two children and came to the realization that he was making a huge mistake. He tried backing up his Jeep, but it wouldn't budge. It was stuck on the track.
汽油味让他感到头晕恶心。双手颤抖着，他举起打火机。胡安又改变了主意。活活烧死将是一种可怕的死法。他开车回到雪佛兰大通大道，然后在铁路交叉口进入了轨道的限制区域，并沿着铁路线平行行驶了大约50码。胡安随后把车停在铁轨上。在接下来的15分钟里，他看着两个孩子的照片，意识到自己犯了一个巨大的错误。他试图倒车，但车动弹不得。它卡在轨道上了。
Juan climbed out of his car and attempted to push it off, but to no avail. He placed a large rock under a rear wheel to leverage the vehicle upwards and forwards. Pressing his foot to the gas pedal, the wheel spun in place and the car didn't budge. As he sat defeated in the front seat, Juan heard the sound of a blaring horn approaching. At 5.59am, Edward Branch was waiting in his car. The barrier along the Chevy Chase Drive level crossing had just lowered in anticipation of a passing train. As Edward waited, he noticed a jeep on the tracks nearby. A double-decker train was barreling towards it. It made contact with the car, resulting in a fiery crash.
胡安爬出车外，试图把它推开，但无济于事。他在后轮下放了一块大石头，试图向上和向前撬动车辆。他踩下油门，车轮在原地打转，车子纹丝不动。当他颓然坐在前座时，胡安听到了逼近的刺耳喇叭声。凌晨5点59分，爱德华·布兰奇（Edward Branch）正在车里等待。雪佛兰大通大道平交道口的栏杆刚刚放下，等待一列火车通过。当爱德华等待时，他注意到轨道上有一辆吉普车。一列双层列车正向它疾驰而来。它与车相撞，引发了一场火灾。
Moments later, a second train traveling in the opposite direction smashed into the carnage. A man suddenly appeared from the side of the tracks, near where the jeep had been parked. He then headed towards the destruction. Juan Alvarez ran to the wreckage and approached a passenger who'd escaped to Metrolink 100 with only minor injuries. Juan asked him what had happened. He was told that the train had crashed and people had died. Juan exclaimed, oh no, and fell to the ground. He was asked if he had anything to do with the collision. Juan gave no response. Instead, he got up and moved onwards.
片刻之后，第二列朝相反方向行驶的列车撞上了残骸。一个男人突然从轨道旁出现，靠近吉普车停放的地方。然后他走向了破坏现场。胡安·阿尔瓦雷斯跑向残骸，接近了一名仅受轻伤并从Metrolink 100次列车逃出的乘客。胡安问他发生了什么事。他被告知火车撞车了，有人死了。胡安惊呼：“哦，不”，然后倒在地上。有人问他是否与这次碰撞有关。胡安没有回答。相反，他站起来继续向前走。
As he walked amongst the injured and dying, Juan held onto a large eagle feather that he carried with him everywhere. He believed that the eagle was an honored animal that guided the souls of the dead to God. By having the feather with him at that moment, Juan felt he was assisting the dying passengers to enter heaven. Raymunda Basana was going about her typical morning in Glendale when, at 6.15am, Juan Alvarez entered her home. Raymunda was Juan's landlady and the pair had a good relationship. In lieu of paying monetary rent, Juan worked as a maintenance man for Raymunda. That day, Raymunda was disturbed to find Juan in her home with his arms and chest covered in blood. Clutched tightly in his hand was a pair of blooded scissors.
当他在伤者和垂死者中行走时，胡安紧紧抓着他随身携带的一根大鹰羽毛。他相信鹰是一种受人尊敬的动物，能引导死者的灵魂去见上帝。在那一刻随身带着羽毛，胡安觉得自己在帮助垂死的乘客进入天堂。雷蒙达·巴萨纳（Raymunda Basana）正在格伦代尔过着她典型的早晨，这时，凌晨6点15分，胡安·阿尔瓦雷斯进入了她的家。雷蒙达是胡安的房东，两人关系很好。胡安不付现金房租，而是为雷蒙达做维修工。那天，雷蒙达不安地发现胡安在她的家里，手臂和胸口沾满了血。他手里紧紧抓着一把带血的剪刀。
Juan took Raymunda's phone. He phoned his wife, speaking in a garbled mixture of Spanish and English. He then called a cousin who had supported him throughout his time in LA. He left him a voicemail. I didn't mean this. A lot of innocent people died. I don't deserve to live. I apologize for everything. Please pray for me. Please. As he made the calls, Juan stabbed himself in the chest with the scissors. Raymunda contacted 911. Juan told first responders that he had, quote, Hurt those people. I jumped in front of the train. Officers arrived at the hospital while Juan Alvarez was undergoing treatment for his self-inflicted, non-life-threatening stab wounds. Juan asked how the people on the trains were before explaining what he had done. He added,
胡安拿走了雷蒙达的电话。他给妻子打了电话，用西班牙语和英语的混合语含糊不清地说话。然后他给一位在他洛杉矶期间一直支持他的表弟打了电话。他留下了语音留言。“我不是故意的。很多无辜的人死了。我不配活着。我为一切道歉。请为我祈祷。求你了。”在打电话时，胡安用剪刀刺向自己的胸口。雷蒙达联系了911。胡安告诉急救人员，他“伤害了那些人。我跳到了火车前面。”警察到达医院时，胡安·阿尔瓦雷斯正在接受自残、无生命危险的刺伤治疗。胡安询问火车上的人情况如何，然后解释了他所做的事情。他补充说，
I want life or death row. I deserve it. Juan was arrested and held in custody. Described as distraught and remorseful but cooperative, he was charged with one count of arson, one count of train wrecking with intent to cause derailment, and 11 counts of first-degree murder with special circumstances. Special circumstances arose due to there being multiple victims, and so, if found guilty, Juan faced the death penalty. Carmelita visited her husband while he was in custody. She told the Washington Post about the moment he decided not to end his own life, quote, He was there and out of nowhere he saw a light, not the light from the train. He said he felt like there was a presence from God telling him to get away.
“我想要终身监禁或死刑。我罪有应得。”胡安被捕并被拘留。他被描述为心烦意乱、充满悔恨但很配合，被控一项纵火罪、一项蓄意导致脱轨的火车破坏罪，以及11项带有特殊情况的一级谋杀罪。特殊情况是因为有多个受害者，因此，如果罪名成立，胡安将面临死刑。卡梅利塔在胡安被拘留期间探望了他。她告诉《华盛顿邮报》他决定不结束自己生命的那一刻，“他在那里，突然间他看到了一道光，不是火车的光。他说他感觉上帝的存在告诉他离开。”
The restraining order that Carmelita had previously placed on Juan was also in part to his mental state. His behavior had increasingly become erratic and threatening lately. He exhibited paranoia and obsessive jealousy and accused her of cheating on him with his cousin, neighbors, co-workers, and strangers. He suspected Carmelita recorded him with hidden cameras in his bedroom. He also believed she was making pornography videos with other people. Juan purchased a firearm and repeatedly threatened Carmelita's lovers, all of whom were figments of his imagination. He even considered killing Carmelita. Juan was opposed to seeking psychiatric help, so Carmelita sought a restraining order to protect herself and their children.
卡梅利塔之前对胡安申请的限制令也部分是因为他的精神状态。他的行为最近变得越来越古怪和具有威胁性。他表现出偏执和强迫性的嫉妒，指责她与他的表弟、邻居、同事和陌生人有染。他怀疑卡梅利塔在他的卧室里安装了隐藏摄像头监视他。他还认为她和别人在拍色情录像。胡安购买了枪支，并多次威胁卡梅利塔的情人，所有这些人都是他想象出来的。他甚至考虑过杀死卡梅利塔。胡安反对寻求精神病治疗，所以卡梅利塔寻求限制令来保护自己和他们的孩子。
This caused Juan's lifelong suicidal inclination to re-emerge. He had told others of his intentions to end his life. In preparation for the trial, Juan Ávarez was interviewed by a number of psychiatrists. Juan diagnosed him with a psychotic mood disorder and attributed Juan's impulsive behavior and irritability to this disorder. Another psychiatrist was of the opinion that Juan showed logical, goal-oriented behavior on the day of the train crash. Others theorized that Juan's desire to end his own life was the result of a depressing come-down of a methamphetamine high, which he admitted to using prior to the train crash. On the morning of the train crash, Juan recalled Carmelita belittling him from the backseat of his Jeep as he drove around searching for the ideal place to take his life.
这导致胡安终身的自杀倾向再次出现。他曾向他人表达过结束自己生命的意图。在审判准备阶段，胡安·阿尔瓦雷斯接受了几位精神病学家的采访。胡安诊断他患有精神病性心境障碍，并将胡安冲动的行为和易怒归因于这种障碍。另一位精神病学家认为，胡安在火车事故当天表现出逻辑性、目标导向的行为。其他人则推测，胡安结束自己生命的愿望是甲基苯丙胺兴奋后的抑郁后果，他承认在火车事故前使用过。在火车事故那天早上，胡安回忆起卡梅利塔在他开车四处寻找结束生命的最佳地点时，在后座贬低他。
At one point, she was joined by a man Juan identified as one of her lovers. However, there were no others in the vehicle at the time. They were delusions. During this bickering, Juan contemplated visiting Carmelita at work and killing her, but it was too early for her to be there. Even though Juan knew that Carmelita couldn't be in two places at once, he was still convinced she was sitting behind him with another man. He heard the pair remarking, Look at how stupid he is. He can't even see us. Their words angered Juan and his attention turned to the railway tracks. He believed if he took his life there, it would get Carmelita's attention and make her feel bad.
有一次，一个男人加入了她，胡安认定那是她的情人之一。然而，当时车里没有其他人。那是幻觉。在这次争吵中，胡安考虑去卡梅利塔工作的地方杀了她，但她还没到那里。尽管胡安知道卡梅利塔不可能同时出现在两个地方，但他仍然确信她正坐在他身后，和另一个男人在一起。他听到两人评论说：“看他有多蠢。他甚至看不到我们。”他们的话激怒了胡安，他的注意力转向了铁轨。他认为如果他在那里结束生命，会引起卡梅利塔的注意，让她感到难过。
Juan maintained that he didn't realize a passenger train would approach. He expected a cargo train that would smash through his car and continue along without derailing. He claimed he wasn't thinking about the consequences of his actions, including that others could be harmed or killed by his plan. He knew of an instance wherein a train collided with a taxi. The taxi's occupants were killed, but no one on the train was harmed. Juan Alvarez's trial began in late April 2008. His defense team insisted that Juan never intended for anyone to be hurt by his actions. He wanted to take his own life, but changed his mind at the last moment. This desire had lingered since childhood, prompted by physical and sexual abuse, drug dependency, untreated mental health issues, and a failing marriage.
胡安坚持认为他没有意识到客运列车会驶来。他以为是一列货运列车，会撞穿他的车，然后继续行驶而不会脱轨。他声称他没有考虑自己行为的后果，包括其他人可能会因为他的计划而受到伤害或死亡。他知道一个火车与出租车相撞的例子。出租车里的乘客死了，但火车上没有人受伤。胡安·阿尔瓦雷斯的审判于2008年4月下旬开始。他的辩护团队坚持认为胡安从未打算让任何人受到伤害。他想结束自己的生命，但在最后一刻改变了主意。这种愿望自童年以来一直挥之不去，是由身体和性虐待、药物依赖、未治疗的心理健康问题和失败的婚姻引起的。
Juan offered the families of his victims an apology in court, maintaining that he never intended to hurt their loved ones. In contrast, the prosecution argued that Juan Alvarez had no intention of taking his own life. Rather, he wanted to create a grand spectacle that would get his wife's attention and pity, so she would take him back. There were elements about Juan's story that didn't add up to evidence at the scene. Juan claimed that he had poured gasoline on himself and his vehicle, with the initial intention to set himself alight. His clothing from that day tested positive for traces of gasoline, but an amount that arson investigators attributed to splashback when pouring it all over his vehicle, not directly over himself. Witnesses who had interacted with Juan immediately after the crash noted that he didn't smell of gasoline. Doctors who had treated him didn't recall Juan's eyes or skin as being red, inflamed, or irritated, tell tale signs of prolonged exposure to gasoline.
胡安在法庭上向受害者家属道歉，坚称他从未打算伤害他们所爱的人。相比之下，检方辩称胡安·阿尔瓦雷斯根本没有结束自己生命的意图。相反，他想制造一场盛大的奇观，以引起妻子的注意和怜悯，这样她就会回心转意。胡安的故事中有些要素与现场证据不符。胡安声称他把汽油倒在自己和车上，最初打算自焚。他那天的衣服检测出有汽油痕迹，但纵火调查人员认为这是在把汽油倒在车上时溅到的，而不是直接倒在自己身上。事故发生后立即与胡安接触的目击者指出，他身上没有汽油味。治疗他的医生不记得胡安的眼睛或皮肤有发红、发炎或刺激的迹象，这些都是长期接触汽油的明显迹象。
The prosecution insisted that Juan didn't make the bona fide attempt to take his own life, as he alleged. Furthermore, an expert witness revealed that fire damage on the jeep's parking brake assembly indicated that it was activated at the time of impact. This meant the car was in park, which contradicted Juan's claims that he had made considerable effort to try and move the jeep to avoid a collision. Witnesses reported that only the car's passenger door was open at the time it was demolished, which contradicted Juan's claims that he had thrown himself from the driver's side seconds before impact. Additionally, the vehicle's headlights were off, indicating Juan didn't intend for it to be seen until it was too late. There was no debate that the gasoline Juan had poured over his jeep was a contributing factor in starting the blaze that consumed Metrolink 100's front passenger carriage. The arson count was crucial to Juan's case. The felony statute on arson in California meant that if Juan was found guilty of causing the fire, he was to be held liable for the murders, even if he didn't intend to kill anyone.
检方坚持认为胡安并没有像他声称的那样进行真正的自杀尝试。此外，一位专家证人透露，吉普车驻车制动装置上的火灾损坏表明它在撞击时已启动。这意味着车处于停车档，这与胡安声称他曾努力尝试移动吉普车以避免碰撞的说法相矛盾。目击者报告说，在车被撞毁时，只有乘客侧车门是开着的，这与胡安声称他在撞击前几秒钟从驾驶侧跳出的说法相矛盾。此外，车辆的车灯是关着的，表明胡安不打算让它被看到，直到为时已晚。毫无疑问，胡安倒在吉普车上的汽油是引发大火并吞噬Metrolink 100次列车前客车车厢的一个促成因素。纵火罪名对胡安的案件至关重要。加州的纵火重罪法规意味着，如果胡安被判纵火罪成立，即使他无意杀人，也要对谋杀负责。
Even the defense's expert witness agreed with most of the prosecution's findings. They conceded that if a person poured gasoline over their vehicle and waited for a train to collide with it, then they probably intended for a fire to start, using the train as an ignition source. After three hours of deliberation, the jury found Juan Alvarez guilty of one count of arson and of all 11 counts of first-degree murder with special circumstances. They found him not guilty of train wrecking, unsatisfied that he intended to derail the train. Nevertheless, the guilty verdict ensured Juan would face a possible death sentence. In talking to the Daily News, three members of the jury said they likely would not have convicted Juan Alvarez of murder had it not been for the felony statute on arson. The jury foreman said he was reckless, he's a dangerous man, but I don't think he had any intention. The week prior to the verdict, the jury inspected four of the train cars damaged in the collision.
甚至辩方的专家证人也同意检方的大部分调查结果。他们承认，如果一个人把汽油倒在车上并等待火车撞上它，那么他们很可能打算引发火灾，利用火车作为点火源。经过三个小时的审议，陪审团裁定胡安·阿尔瓦雷斯一项纵火罪和所有11项带有特殊情况的一级谋杀罪成立。他们裁定他火车破坏罪不成立，认为没有证据表明他蓄意使火车脱轨。尽管如此，有罪判决确保胡安将面临可能的死刑。在与《每日新闻》交谈时，三名陪审员表示，如果不是因为纵火重罪法规，他们可能不会判胡安·阿尔瓦雷斯谋杀罪。陪审团领班说，他很鲁莽，他是一个危险的人，但我不认为他有任何意图。在判决前一周，陪审团检查了碰撞中损坏的四节火车车厢。
Rather than implicate Juan Alvarez, the wreckage had the opposite effect. The jury foreman told the Daily News that seeing the wreckage reaffirmed his belief that Juan did not expect anyone to get injured. Quote, seeing how big those trains were and how heavy they were, I really don't think a reasonable person would expect a train to derail by parking their car on the tracks. In the weeks following the trial, the jury opted to remove the death penalty as a possible sentence, reasoning that Juan Alvarez never intended to kill. Juan's wife and cousin were featured in the LA Times pleading for leniency, citing that he belonged in a mental institution, not on death row. They regretted not getting Juan the psychiatric help he needed, saying they believed the catastrophe could have been avoided if they had. The Superior Court judge was far more skeptical of Juan Alvarez. He didn't believe that Juan was unaware that his actions would have dire consequences for others.
这些残骸非但没有牵连胡安·阿尔瓦雷斯，反而产生了相反的效果。陪审团领班告诉《每日新闻》，看到残骸重申了他的信念，即胡安没有预料到会有人受伤。“看到那些火车有多大、多重，我真的不认为一个理性的人会预料到把车停在铁轨上会导致火车脱轨。”审判后的几周里，陪审团选择取消死刑作为可能的判决，理由是胡安·阿尔瓦雷斯从未打算杀人。胡安的妻子和表弟在《洛杉矶时报》上恳求宽大处理，称他应该被关进精神病院，而不是死囚牢房。他们后悔没有让胡安得到他需要的精神病治疗，并表示他们相信如果他们这样做了，这场灾难本可以避免。高等法院法官对胡安·阿尔瓦雷斯持怀疑态度。他不相信胡安不知道他的行为会给他人带来可怕的后果。
He told Alvarez that the phone message he left for his cousin following the crash seemed set up, like somebody playing a part, and that it sounded like a very bad actor trying to convince the person that he really feels as he says he does, and it doesn't ring true. The judge told Juan, I don't believe for a minute you intended to kill yourself or harm yourself in any way. I think you were setting up a scenario so you could go back to your family. If there was a sentence known as forever in state prison, I would give it to you. What I'm going to do is almost the equivalent, and I agree that these 11 people who died and their families deserve a maximum sentence in this case. Juan was given 11 consecutive life sentences.
他告诉阿尔瓦雷斯，他在事故后给表弟留下的电话留言似乎是预先安排好的，就像有人在演戏，听起来像是一个非常糟糕的演员试图说服对方他真的像他说的那样感受，这听起来不真实。法官告诉胡安：“我一点也不相信你打算自杀或以任何方式伤害自己。我认为你是在设置一个场景，这样你就可以回到你的家人身边。如果有一种判决叫在州立监狱里永远待下去，我会给你的。我要做的是几乎等同的判决，我同意这11名死者和他们的家人在这个案件中应该得到最高刑罚。”胡安被判处11个连续的终身监禁。
It was the maximum sentence that could be awarded given that the death penalty had been taken off the table. Juan Alvarez appealed his conviction in 2012, arguing in part that the prosecution failed to prove a connection between the arson he committed and the deaths of the victims. His appeal failed. A number of the survivors of the Glendale train crash filed a civil lawsuit against Metrolink, claiming that the tragedy could have been avoided, had the engineer of Metrolink 100, Bruce Gray, followed protocol. During the trial, Bruce testified that in the seconds before the crash, he saw what appeared to be a reflection coming from a vehicle about three-quarters of a mile ahead. Bruce said he became fixated on the area, and when he saw an outline of the jeep, he hit the train's emergency brakes. However, the black box taken from the train wreckage revealed that the service brakes had only been applied initially, with a few critical seconds passing before the emergency brakes were activated. The attorney representing the victims argued that had Bruce Gray applied the brakes when he said he had a trial, the crash could have been avoided.
这是在死刑被排除后所能判处的最高刑罚。胡安·阿尔瓦雷斯在2012年对他的定罪提出上诉，部分理由是检方未能证明他所犯的纵火罪与受害者死亡之间的联系。他的上诉失败了。格伦代尔火车事故的一些幸存者对Metrolink提起了民事诉讼，声称如果Metrolink 100次列车的工程师布鲁斯·格雷遵循规程，这场悲剧本可以避免。在审判期间，布鲁斯作证说，在撞车前几秒钟，他看到前方约四分之三英里处有一辆车发出的反射光。布鲁斯说他开始盯着那个区域，当他看到吉普车的轮廓时，他踩下了火车的紧急制动器。然而，从火车残骸中取出的黑匣子显示，行车制动器最初只是被应用，在紧急制动器启动前经过了几个关键的秒数。代表受害者的律师辩称，如果布鲁斯·格雷在审判时所说的那样踩下刹车，撞车事故本可以避免。
Metrolink settled the lawsuit, with a $39 million combined payout. Following the Glendale train crash, Metrolink's fleet underwent changes, with the spokesman claiming that it was now the safest commuter rail line in the country. Their trains were fitted out with crash energy management technology that included bumpers designed to absorb the lion's share of energy from a collision. 11 unrelated fates were sealed when Juan Alvarez abandoned his jeep on the Ventura line near Glendale train station on January 26, 2005. Manuel Alcalá aged 51, Julia Bennett aged 44, Alfonso Caballero aged 62, Elizabeth Hill aged 65, Scott McCown aged 42, William Perrin aged 53, James Totino aged 47, and Don Wiley aged 58 lost their lives aboard Metrolink 100. Leonard Romero aged 53, Henry Kalinsky aged 39, and the train's engineer, Thomas Ormiston aged 58, died on Metrolink 901. Thomas had worked on trains since 1972. His job was often a topic of conversation whenever he dropped his car off to his mechanic and friend, Walter. During one visit, the pair spoke of the possibility of a train crash occurring after reading about similar incidents in the papers.
Metrolink以3900万美元的赔偿金达成了和解。格伦代尔火车事故后，Metrolink的车队进行了更换，发言人声称它现在是全国最安全的通勤铁路线。他们的火车配备了碰撞能量管理技术，包括旨在吸收碰撞中大部分能量的保险杠。2005年1月26日，当胡安·阿尔瓦雷斯在格伦代尔火车站附近的文图拉线（Ventura line）上遗弃他的吉普车时，11个不相关的命运被封存了。51岁的曼努埃尔·阿尔卡拉（Manuel Alcalá）、44岁的朱莉娅·贝内特（Julia Bennett）、62岁的阿方索·卡巴列罗（Alfonso Caballero）、65岁的伊丽莎白·希尔（Elizabeth Hill）、42岁的斯科特·麦考恩（Scott McCown）、53岁的威廉·佩林（William Perrin）、47岁的詹姆斯·托蒂诺（James Totino）和58岁的唐·威利（Don Wiley）在Metrolink 100次列车上丧生。53岁的伦纳德·罗梅罗（Leonard Romero）、39岁的亨利·卡林斯基（Henry Kalinsky）和列车工程师、58岁的托马斯·奥米斯顿（Thomas Ormiston）死于Metrolink 901次列车。托马斯自1972年以来一直从事火车工作。每当他把车送到他的机械师兼朋友沃尔特（Walter）那里时，他的工作经常成为谈话的话题。在一次访问中，两人在报纸上读到类似事件后，谈到了发生火车事故的可能性。
Walter asked Thomas if he was worried about such things. No, it's okay, Thomas responded. Accidents will happen. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
沃尔特问托马斯是否担心这些事情。“不，没关系，”托马斯回答。“事故总会发生的。”你 目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。